I was very lucky to be
asked to come and speak
at MIT a couple of years ago.
And so I had a chance
to spend a bit of time
and see this
institution that I'd
heard of all my life that
had produced invention,
which was always my interest.
Rather than it
being about design,
it was about ideas that
drive the world forward.
And so it was thrilling when I
suddenly got, out of the blue,
this notification that I've
been chosen for this award.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So when I was little,
I was interested
and wanted to be
an inventor, but it
was like that word wasn't
there in the world around me.
If you studied painting or
studied food or writing,
it seemed invention
was the key thing.
But there was no way you could
study that, and so in a way,
I had to make up my own
version of an education
to make it work out somehow.
And design seemed
the right word,
and so it's been
exciting for me now
finding that
invention actually is
the nectar, is the thing
that's critical to progress.
And MIT is a place which
is about invention.
And so I suppose there was
a sense of slight coming
home, finding this place.
Like Building 20 had, I think,
nine Nobel Prize winners
worked from Building
20 while it was there.
And there seemed to
be a different level
of exceptional focus on
progress through ideas
and developing those ideas.
And my grandfather had these
books on the great engineers,
and I found those very
clear that engineering
was about invention.
Whether you call something
design or engineering
or architecture, to
me, it's all the same.
And it felt like MIT
did put it all together
and was about ideas.
So getting this letter
suddenly, saying
you're being offered this
incredible honor award,
my heart went, ahh!
As a sort of link to somewhere
whose values I cherish.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I found in design,
it's very interesting,
the notion of being taught.
Because in a sense, my
best tutors, professors,
were teachers who
didn't try to teach me
in a very demonstrative way.
Actually, they
were facilitators.
They allowed me to
jump and encouraged,
and they facilitated,
but they certainly
didn't boss you around.
The worst ones were the ones who
tried to tell you what to do,
and they were the ones that
it was really important to not
take too seriously.
And I think that spirit
matters now more than ever,
when we have access to the
world's information in the way
that we do.
So I think we're in an
interesting time for teaching,
and I think any student
should have a healthy ability
to not listen to a tutor.
And because you will always have
lots of people saying things,
and people come from
their own places,
but the best, most
brilliant teachers
are watching and listening,
and it's not about them.
And they're just
helping you to jump.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I enjoyed in the interaction
that myself and my colleague
had with the students
was that we didn't
know who was an architect,
who was an engineer, who
was a biologist.
We didn't know.
You couldn't tell.
It didn't matter.
What mattered was the intensity
of attention and focus
and journey and
hunger to find ideas.
And that's what we
experienced, and that's
the experience I've
always had, and I've
found that the most
interesting people aren't
bothered by titles.
They're just on a hunt and are
hungry and searching, working
with people, about a goal,
rather than official pompous
titling of things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We've been in a fascinating
time in the big arc of history
with the digital
revolution that's
happened over the
last two decades
and in my working
life, running a studio.
And the advent of all
the layers of innovation
that have come from this
digital new dimensions
have meant that it seemed
like the physical would
be less important.
And it's felt to me that
that's not the case.
Actually, they have
been a platform
to lift and create even more
importance to the physical.
And so actually, you can't get
away with lazy place-making
anymore when you can
buy things from home,
when you can study from home.
And so people are making
their homes better.
Why would you go somewhere?
You wouldn't go there
unless it means something
to your emotion.
And in the past, there
could be lazy place-making,
because you had to go there
anyway to buy your bread
or to go and see a doctor
or to get a degree.
And now that you don't have
to, places have to work harder.
What are they for?
In the case of an
education institution,
it's to bring students
together to have
extraordinary interaction.
Otherwise, they can just
stay at home and stay in bed,
get their PhD.
If only it were that simple.
But it kind of is
getting that simple.
But we're nothing without
connecting on a deep level,
and so places need to bring
people together in special ways
and mean something.
And so the duplication that
was possible in the past
isn't possible anymore,
so this hyper-physicality
is what I feel we've
been immersing ourselves
in the studio like a research
project over the last two
decades, and it's
something that I think
is more important than ever.
And I was really
curious how the students
would respond with that
provocation thrown to them.
And it was really interesting
what they came up with,
and it was exciting to see
the experiments and tests.
It's really going some very
interesting directions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I wanted to thank the
Council, the students,
and the professors, and the
McDermott Prize itself--
family-- for this amazing award.
For me, it's an
encouraging thing.
It's not something
about the past.
For me, it's an
encouragement that people
are interested in
the development work
that we've been doing as
a team and that there's
a sort of hand of
friendship reaching out
from a group of people
going, yeah, yeah.
Come on, keep going.
Because I don't feel I'm
any finished article.
I feel that we've just
got going as a studio.
And as the students at MIT
must feel, to be at MIT
is a great sign of encouragement
and egging-on to do things.
So I feel egged on by great
egger-onners and people who
themselves are being egged on.
So I feel less lonely,
because sometimes you
can feel by yourself
with your team,
and to have that
hand of friendship--
which maybe sounds a
bit cheesy, but it's
a hand of friendship from
somewhere as incredible as MIT
and a family that was based on
innovation, like the McDermott
family--
is very exciting.
And we're so grateful.
I'll speak on
behalf of my studio.
I'm nothing without my studio.
[MUSIC PLAYING]